human beings are into altered states of
consciousness Steven Kotler and Jamie
wheel have talked about the altered
States economy we are willing to spend
money to perceive the world in a
different way
whether it's our fierce appetite
mind-altering drugs or virtual reality
technologies like cinema or even going
into a casino or hiring a prostitute
human beings will spend to feel
different to go into an altered state
today we're seeing a renaissance in the
cycle of therapeutic uses of psychedelic
substances like MDMA or psilocybin
mushrooms where human beings are now
saying that within the realm of altered
states might be a solution to our
existential ills that we might finally
bridge a tunnel between ourselves and
the infinite so it is in the end through
altered states that we may even find our
salvation and I think this is really
interesting you know I love to go to the
movies I love to go into a liminal
trance when I lose myself in an
alternate reality I like to intervene
while I'm awake
I like to dream at night too but if we
can treat our normal waking lives that's
something that is unbounded as our
dreams that is as unbounded as cinema
perhaps there in live the future of
human consciousness when technology
right can be sourced to take care of all
of our ills and to handle our menial
tasks might wake free you
imagination into a waking dream state a
lucid dream in which we live
might we all fall into the rabbit hole
might we all inhabit Wonderland might we
all get a pass to Willy Wonka's
chocolate factory its neverending story
folks and this is where we're gonna live
I mean look virtual reality technologies
that are emerging now are indicative we
are going to be living in world rendered
at the speed of thought condensations of
human imagination you know universe is
built out of life and mind and
intentionality man I can't wait the
Garden of Eden for sale real soon
you